what is one moment of this season that
you're particularly proud of
great question thank you for asking
thank you for saying that
uh thank you for thanking me for saying
thank you for thanking me thank you for
thinking thicky thinking
um i
feel like the
yeah i don't know i don't know i i i
don't i truly love all of it
i do and if i didn't love it
i've got it like that around here mm-hmm
uh i don't know i do love our how do we
get yours yeah because i think
because it's something i do not have the
ability to do
i i don't know any facts
i don't know
um
i don't know any stance i can't i don't
know any um special nuggets of unknown
uh black history oh i don't know
um
but it when i
received those
how did we get here's i learned so much
and i'm like
oh you know it it burns in my brain and
i'm like i can't be the only human being
with this information i gotta get it out
there yeah we should say that most of
our all of our how do we get here
segments are written by either michael
harriott erica buddington or zachary
stevens and then we have an amazing
writer named jill twist who adds a bunch
of jokes to them but i right i also
don't have that skill and i feel like
between you and me in our careers we've
learned almost every kind of writing
we've done sketches and songs and
monologue jokes you've written a
broadway show i've written a screenplay
i've written some very terrible plays
but i feel like there's almost no kind
of writing no structure writing that i
can't figure out if i try how long
enough and i'm truly humbled by the how
do we get here segment i'm like for if i
tried for a million years i wouldn't
have that skill and i feel so grateful
that we found folks who are willing to
bring that to the show yeah it's so
shocking that someone can be
that funny and that factual yeah i
didn't know you could do that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you